no es cierto.
Con la edad viene la apariencia de respetabilidad
y una apariencia de verdades incómodas.
Pero lo que era cierto era que mis padres,
mi madre, y mi padre estaban de acuerdo
en no confiar mi educación al estado.
Así que escuchen.
Decidieron que me enviarían a una escuela privada,
pero mi padre trabajaba en Vauxhall Motors.
Era bastante difícil de financiar una escuela privada
y alimentar a su ejército de niños.
Recuerdo que fui a la escuela
para el examen de ingreso y mi padre dijo
al sacerdote —era una escuela católica—
que quería una mejor "jeducación" para el niño,
pero, él, mi padre,
ni siquiera logró pasar virus,
y mucho menos los exámenes de ingreso.
Pero para financiar mi educación,
tendría que hacer algunas cosas dudosas,
así que mi padre pagaría mi educación
comerciando con bienes ilícitos de la parte trasera del auto,
lo que fue aún más difícil porque
el auto no era de mi padre, por cierto.
Mi padre aspiraba a tener un auto así,
pero mi padre tenía un mini abollado
y nunca, siendo un jamaicano inmigrado a este país,
tuvo permiso de conducir,
nunca tuvo ningún tipo de seguro, impuesto de circulación o ITV.
Pensó: "Yo sé conducir;
¿por qué necesito la validación del estado?"
Pero se hizo un poco difícil cuando nos detuvo la policía,
y la policía nos detuvo muchas veces,
y me impresionó la forma en
que mi padre trataba con la policía.
Ascendía al policía inmediatamente,
por lo que el policía Bloggs se convertía en el Inspector criminalista Bloggs
en el transcurso de la conversación.
y nos despedía alegremente con la mano.
Así que mi padre desplegaba lo que en Jamaica
se llama "hacerse el tonto para pillar como listo".
Pero también reafirmaba la idea
de que en realidad estaba discriminado
o menospreciado por la policía,
—como niño de 10 años, lo veía—
pero también existía una ambivalencia hacia la autoridad.
Así, por un lado, había
una burla de la autoridad,
pero por otro lado, había una deferencia
hacia la autoridad,
y estos pueblos del Caribe
tienen una obediencia exagerada hacia la autoridad,
que es muy llamativo, muy extraño,
porque los inmigrantes son personas muy valientes.
Dejan sus casas. Mi padre y mi madre
dejaron Jamaica y viajaron unos 6500 km,
y, sin embargo, el viaje les infantilizó.
Eran tímidos,
y, en algún lugar, a lo largo de la línea,
el orden natural se invirtió.
Los niños se convirtieron en los padres de los padres.
Las personas del Caribe llegaron a este país con un plan de 5 años:
iban a trabajar, ganar algo de dinero, y luego volver,
pero los cinco años se convirtieron en 10, los 10 se convirtieron en 15,
y antes de darse cuenta, estás cambiando el empapelado de las paredes.
En ese punto, uno sabe que está aquí para quedarse.
Aunque aún exista la clase de temporalidad
que nuestros padres sentían por estar aquí,
pero nosotros, los niños sabíamos que el juego había terminado.
Creo que había una sensación de que
que no podrían continuar con los ideales
de la vida que ellos esperaban.
La realidad era muy diferente.
Y también, era cierta la realidad
de tratar de educarme.
Después de haber iniciado el proceso, mi padre no continuó.
Dejó a mi madre que me educara,
y como George Lamming diría,
fue mi madre quien me engendró.
Incluso, en su ausencia, ese viejo mantra se mantuvo:
Te están vigilando.
Pero esa vigilancia ardiente puede llevar a la ansiedad,
tanto es así que años más tarde, cuando yo estaba investigando
por qué a tantos jóvenes negros
se les diagnosticó esquizofrenia,
6 veces más de lo que deberían ser,
no me sorprendió escuchar al psiquiatra decir:
"Los negros son educados en la paranoia".
Y me pregunto qué diría Bageye al respecto.
Ahora al tener también un hijo de 10 años,
torné mi atención a Bageye
y fui en su búsqueda.
Estaba de nuevo en Luton, tenía ahora de 82 años,
y yo no lo había visto desde hacía unos 30 años,
y cuando abrió la puerta,
vi a este pequeño hombre pequeño con ojos ondulantes y sonrientes,
y sonreía, y yo nunca antes lo había visto sonreír.
Eso me desconcertó mucho.
Pero nos sentamos, y él estaba con un amigo del Caribe,
hablando de viejos tiempos,
y mi padre me miraba,
y él me miró como si yo fuera a
desaparecer milagrosamente tal y como había aparecido.
Y él se volvió hacia su amigo y le dijo:
"Este chico y yo tenemos una conexión profunda, profunda,
una conexión profunda, profunda".
Pero nunca sentí esa conexión.
Si había un pulso, era muy débil
o apenas nada.
Y en el transcurso de esa reunión casi me sentí
que hacia una audición para ser el hijo de mi padre.
Cuando salió el libro,
obtuve buenas críticas en los periódicos nacionales,
pero el periódico preferido en Luton no es The Guardian,
es el Luton News,
y el Luton News publicó el titular sobre el libro,
"El libro que puede curar una desavenencia de un chico de 32 años".
Y comprendí que también podía representar
la ruptura entre una generación y la siguiente,
entre la gente como yo y la generación de mi padre,
pero no hay tradición en la vida del Caribe
de memorias o biografías.
Era tradición el no conversar sobre las cosas de uno en público.
Pero di la bienvenida a ese título, y pensé que en realidad, sí,
hay una posibilidad de que esto
abriera conversaciones que nunca habíamos tenido antes.
Esto cerrará la brecha generacional, tal vez.
Esto podría ser un instrumento de reparación.
Y yo ni siquiera empecé a sentir que este libro
pudiera ser percibidos por mi padre
como un acto de devoción filial.
Pobre, tonto engañado.
A Bageye le picó lo que él percibió como
la difusión pública de sus defectos.
Se sintió herido por mi traición,
y al día siguiente se fue al periódico
y exigió el derecho de réplica,
y lo consiguió con el titular
"Bageye contraataca".
Y era una cuestión pendiente a mi traición.
Ya no era hijo suyo.
Reconoció en su mente que su reputación
había sido arrastrada por el suelo, y no lo podía permitir.
Tenía que recuperar su dignidad, y así lo hizo,
y en un principio, aunque estaba decepcionado,
llegué a admirar esa postura.
Todavía había llamas chispeando en sus venas,
a pesar de que tenía 82 años.
Y si eso significaba que ahora volveríamos
a 30 años de silencio,
mi padre decía: "Si es así, entonces es así".
Los jamaicanos dicen que no existe nada más que los hechos,
solo hay versiones.
Todos nos contamos versiones de la historia
con las que podemos vivir mejor.
Cada generación construye un edificio
que no está dispuesta o no puede a veces
desmontar,
pero en la escritura, mi versión de la historia
comenzó a cambiar,
y se separa de mí.
Perdí el odio a mi padre.
Yo ya no quiero que se muera o asesinarle,
y me sentí libre,
mucho más libre de lo que nunca antes me había sentido.
Y me pregunto si esa libertad
se le podría transmitir a él.
En esa reunión inicial,
me llamó la atención una cosa que tenía
muy pocas fotografías mías,
siendo un niño pequeño.
Esta es una fotografía mía,
tenía nueve meses.
En la fotografía original,
me sostenía mi padre, Bageye,
pero al separarse mis padres, mi madre
lo extirpó de todos los aspectos de nuestras vidas.
Ella tomó las tijeras y lo recortó de cada fotografía,
y durante años, me dije que la verdad de esta fotografía
era que yo estaba solo,
que no tenía apoyo.
Pero hay otra forma de ver esta fotografía.
Esta es una fotografía con el potencial
para una reunión,
un potencial para reunirse con mi padre,
y en mi anhelo de que mi padre me sostuviera,
salió él a la luz.
En esa primera reunión,
hubo momentos muy difíciles y tensos,
y para disminuir la tensión,
decidimos ir a dar un paseo.
Y mientras caminábamos, me llamó la atención
que yo había vuelto a ser el niño
a pesar de que ser ya más alto que mi padre.
Yo era unos 30 cm más alto que mi padre.
Para mí seguía siendo el hombre grande,
y traté de igualar su paso.
Y me di cuenta de que caminaba
como si todavía estuviera vigilado,
pero yo admiraba su paso.
Caminaba como un hombre
en el lado de los perdedores de la final de la copa
dando los pasos para recoger la medalla de consolación.
Hubo dignidad en la derrota.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)